it's my pleasure to welcome to the
program today jonathan
franklin an investigative journalist who
writes for
the guardian is also author of the 2015
book 438 days an extraordinary
true story of survival at sea which i
recently read and recommended to the
audience
uh jonathan it's it's really great to
have you on yeah thank you so much you
know i'm glad you liked the fisherman
boat
you know story this is a guy who's on a
boat all by himself for 14 months and
somehow survive
so you know for all of us who've been
through lockdown and confinement there's
a lot of interesting issues to help us
get through
yeah well maybe we'll start there so for
people who aren't familiar with the
story
of jose salvador alvarenga he
is originally a salvadoran fisherman who
while working as a fisherman in mexico
in a storm ends up drifting off to sea
in a 25-foot boat
originally with his uh what would it be
called like first mate or just sort of
like an assistant i guess we would say
right
yes and ultimately because of the storm
did not make it back and actually
survived as the title of the book
suggests 438 days now
at the time was the previous longest
known
sort of precarious survival the 70-day
incident
no i think there was another one like
200 or something but this
of 438 days and we're talking on a tiny
boat i mean this is
not much longer than an suv
yeah and and so it's an incredible story
and obviously it exceeds the scope of
our conversation to tell it all but
needless to say
it's an incredible story that is filled
with both
you know everything from innovation in
terms of how he survived to complete and
total heartbreak and the reality of what
happens
uh after being essentially alone for the
large part of that 438 days
when you take a story like that and you
want to tell the story and it's someone
else's story to tell
how much are you interviewing what's
your approach what do your notes look
like and how do you end up turning it
into the coherent narrative that it
became
well it's really interesting you asked
that david because this
was a victim of you know intense trauma
he goes off fishing for the weekend as
you say
he loses his motor he loses his buddy
who actually dies along the trip
he's almost starved to death he's in
huge seas
he has to catch fish with his hand he
has to eat raw birds
and somehow he kept it together and so
when i first heard about this i didn't
believe it i was like
he could he didn't he didn't look he
didn't look so skinny when he came off
the boat some things didn't add up
but on the other hand i figured if he
had faked it that was probably a pretty
amazing story
also so either way i had a story and
i flew to el salvador and i tried to
interview him and he couldn't talk he
was he was so in shock
he i was it was one word answers almost
like yes or no
i spent hours just trying to you know
loosen him up
and he was in shock uh he would sweat he
had nightmares so
it was over the course of five or six
months where i ended up asking him
about 2500 questions which turned into
500 pages of conversations
and those 500 pages of conversations
which uh was an exclusive deal that i
made with him
uh is the basis for the book um
in the book you describe many
conversations and i'm interested in in
narrative nonfiction
there's a lot of different approaches to
dialogue and
and sometimes like just to pick somebody
ben mesrich will sometimes say
that that he's using sort of creatively
recreated dialogue that he feels
tells the gist of what took place but is
not necessarily literally accurate or
that stories may be combined or
separated or
whatever the case may be what was your
approach in
sort of describing and telling the
conversations that took place on the
boat between jose
and and his his crewmate well the
interesting thing here
is that the protagonist jose salvador
alvarenga about 33 years old
had never gone to school after about
second or third grade so he couldn't
read
he couldn't write but he fully
functioned in society
and one of the things i learned is that
when you're illiterate you also have the
ability
to develop an amazing memory because you
got to keep a lot of things in your head
if you can't read or write them down
that's interesting this guy had a
fantastic memory
and i could see it when i would
interview him about a certain scene when
he caught his first bird
and two months later i would interview
him again
and he just nailed it so he really had a
fantastic memory
and he uh you know the
dialogue is on in the book is not that
extensive i only use dialogue that i was
pretty sure
i could um you know get from his side of
the dialogue and then he would tell me
the other side of the dialogue
but the fascinating thing is he's often
doing a monologue because he's out in
the middle of the ocean
so the monologue you know he can tell me
what his monologue was so we have these
amazing scenes where he's talking to a a
whale shark for days and days where
he talks to a whale shark he trains a
bird to be his pet and his pet becomes
i mean the bird becomes his pet and his
companion even when his buddy dies
he props up his buddy and he talks to
the corpse for a week because he figures
talking to a corpse is a lot better than
being totally alone
right um you you mentioned that
it wasn't just you who was skeptical to
some degree
of the story initially and when you
consider that
the the we haven't mentioned this detail
but uh he actually washed ashore
with that same 25-foot boat in the
marshall islands
in the pacific in in the middle of
nowhere and one of the elements that
seems most compelling in in
the story is that of course there's no
doubt that it's the same boat he left
mexico with
how important is that detail in
convincing you and others of the
of the story well that detail like how
did the boat get there i mean
you know you can't fedex a boat
and the interesting thing is when the
guy lands
he has no interest in talking to the
press he refuses to talk to the press
he calls the press cockroaches and he's
trying to forget this trauma if you're
going to scam it it's probably because
you figure that publicity is going to
get you something so if you're going to
scam it
it's unlikely your first move is to tell
the press to blow off
uh there's that but on a science level i
don't know anything about ocean currents
especially when i started this so i went
to the scripps
institution of oceanography in the
university of hawaii
and the us coast guard and all three
volunteered very generously
to use uh tracking software for ocean
currents
drifting boats and the university of
hawaii had just put
a bunch of uh gps drifters in off the
coast of mexico's you know
months earlier and it lines up perfectly
in terms of
if you're gonna throw something like a
boat off the shore of mexico it's gonna
end up in the marshall island so that
part also checks out from all three of
those you know the coast guard
scripts and uh university of hawaii so
this
this is a fascinating story i i
recommend it again to to the audience
the book is 438 days now
to talk about some of the other things
you've done i i want to talk about
um the venezuelan uh
assassin sort of rehab camp in a moment
but before we do that
in the 90s i believe it was when you
were
of reporting for playboy magazine you
interviewed
timothy mcveigh is that that's right
that is right i'm one of the few people
who had an
hour face time face to face with tim
mcveigh in el reno prison
so timothy mcveigh of course uh the
perpetrator of the 1993
world trade center bombing what what are
the circumstances of
of that interview well the circumstances
are is that
i uh i was always curious about mcveigh
because you know a horrendous act i mean
what causes you to put a bomb in a
civilian building
and when i look back on it i found that
mcvay had been in the big red one
infantryman uh very very well decorated
u.s
uh army soldier and when i started to
look at what he did
in the uh first gulf war in 1991
he was involved in a pretty horrendous
massacre
where a bunch of m1 tanks had bulldozers
put on the front of them and instead of
going
trench you know mano amano and the
trench warfare they just buried the
iraqis alive about 2 000 were buried
alive
and reporters at newsweek won a pulitzer
prize for the cover-up of this story
huge you know big deal 2 000 people
buried alive you know that
breaks a few contexts of most codes of
war yeah uh
mcveigh's job was to shoot off the
survivors with machine guns
so you can kind of see that without
justifying blowing up oklahoma which i'm
not doing and i don't want people to
take it that way
you have to understand that the first
time this guy was involved in a huge
horrendous massacre he got medals for it
he was applauded you know he he
he had killed before it's very
interesting and very important i think
to look at the first time he killed
so when i went to the prison that's what
i talked to him about was
his war experience because i had
interviewed everybody
in his tank before i interviewed mcvay
so when i go to interview him my first
question is tim
what was the name of your pet kangaroo
rat when you were in the gulf war
and he's like how do you know i had a
pet kangaroo rat and i was like jose
told me
how you know jose jose was the driver i
went out i was out
snowboarding with jose ah you were
hanging out with jose yeah and so
all of a sudden all those barriers broke
down and he's just giving me the inside
story of
what he did in iraq and how for him
oklahoma city was an echo of uh violence
perpetuated by the u.s government
against uh
all these people who were buried alive
in the trench so there was for me
i thought it was very important to
figure out you know where does somebody
go
that kind of hyper violent yeah one one
of the
commonalities that i've heard from folks
who have
interviewed those uh who are
known for or or have committed just
disgustingly
extreme acts of violence is that when
they sit down with them in a room
there's two things that are common
one how sort of unremarkable they are
sometimes physically
some i mean i think i think with totally
true totally true in this case
yeah i mean i think like with charles
manson that's a big thing where he's
just
you know this little just kind of this
small unremarkable guy
but also and this is a weird term to use
how
normal sometimes these folks can seem
and there's a lot of kind of
connotations to that term but but what
was your sort of like general impression
of the man exactly
i totally agree with you because people
you know people want to see a monster
and probably i wanted to see a monster
and i couldn't help think like this is
the guy who like the neighbor who
shovels your driveway in the snow you
know he's a guy he's from buffalo new
york so
he knows about shoveling snow right um
and
uh or it's the kind of guy you could
talk at a bar um
he was he was clearly intelligent you
know sophisticated vocabulary
pretty damn good writer um you know you
can call him misguided insane whatever
but
the guy had done a fair amount of
reading and you know he had he had his
own political philosophy whether you
believe it or follow it
isn't the point really but you know this
was not some some jackass this was a guy
who for his own his own twisted reasons
or in his mind his own
logical reasons uh felt he had to attack
the us government
and so i really like i said i i was very
interested in finding out about his
first kill
when um when when i've talked to former
uh kkk types white nationalists etc one
of the things that's frequently
mentioned is that the way they got
pulled into their ex their extreme
ideology in the first place
came typically from a sort of
opportunistic situation typically they
describe
lacking a feeling of purpose or empathy
given towards them
as children or as teenagers at some
point in their lives
and the people that brought this uh
extreme ideology to them
bro the ideology really could have been
anything but it was the fact that
someone was paying attention to them
there was something approximating hey
somebody seems to care about me
no i call it tribal you know a tribe has
adopted me
i i saw this i went to las vegas and
spent a bunch of time with the young
teenage nazis of las vegas and
why were they nazis not because they
were anti-semitic or because they knew
much about hitler
it's because their parents were working
24 7 and they're 17 year olds and the
people who scooped them up were a bunch
of nutcase you know white supremacists
right the ideology could have been
anything that they were sucked into
muslim it could have been
green greenpeace i mean they you know
they needed they needed to pre you know
a tribe they could have easily been
protesting against
tar sands and doing something you know
my views positive for the world they
could have
you know they could have been building
houses for the poor they needed to be
part of a tribe they found a pretty
terrible tribe but
you can't deny that most 17 year old
need a tribe and
their parents are not usually included
so how does that compare
thinking now of when you spent this time
with
the a for former uh hitmen
in venezuela how how does it compare
with how they were originally pulled
into being hitmen
exactly i think i think these guys could
have been hit many of the carbon soccer
stars you know
what happened is i have some friends in
venezuela and
they told me they were running a rehab
camp for hitman i was like what
and so i flew out there and drove out
there and went out to the
back waters of uh venezuela and sure
enough there was a
hitman rehab camp and they said i could
go camping with the newest group who
were
seven or nine different heads of
different uh gangs
and they were guys who hated each other
who would have likely killed each other
who had sent their assassins to kill
each other each other's troops
so they were stripped of their weapons
and they were just given like
flour and corn and matches
and and they were stuck on the top of a
hill surrounded by armed guards and they
had to just hang out for two or three
days
cooking eating and um you know talking
around the campfire
but so who who organizes that i mean in
other words how how does one get into a
position to be one of the hitmen that's
part of that is it is it under duress
that they're doing
this or oh they get nope they get they
get recruited by a local businessman who
had been
uh a victim of armed robbery and when he
started to poke into the armed robbery
suspects
he realized they were uh hitmen and
he offered them uh instead of turning
them into the cops he offered to let
them uh
work on his on his his rump in his rum
factory he's a big rum factory
so he tried to get them rehabbed them on
his own and then they started they
showed up with the whole
the whole gang it's like you know you're
taking a stray dog and then the whole
pack comes in he took in two of these
guys and
the next monday they were all piling
saying we want to be rehab so
he hired a psychologist he hired some
former cops
and then they go head hunting they
single out the most dangerous gang
leaders in the hills outside caracas
and they and they convince them which is
not an easy process
to come uh try and go straight and
i was there living with them for about
maybe two or three days on this
mountaintop
with all these killers and i just had a
little video camera and i was just
videotaping them getting them to confess
their sins
and so what what stands out to you about
those conversations and those
interactions
pretty remarkable that you can have a
group of 21 year olds who like give
zero value to human life i don't know
who to blame but they just
you know they would kill a taxi driver
because they didn't want to pay five
bucks
you know they uh they one guy killed the
classmate because he made fun of him in
seventh grade you know about his
homework
and these guys were hardcore um and they
assumed they were gonna die
if you if you lived to be 29 they called
your grandfather you become a grant you
know that was like
like a noble title no nobody was
expected to make it to 30.
so when you have that kind of
hopelessness
apparently it's still kind of shocking
you know killing somebody for money or
for fun or for
because you're in a bad mood is
extremely common in a place like
venezuela where
if you give me a thousand dollars i
could probably get a rocket launcher i
mean it's just there's a huge black
market of guns in venezuela so
uh you know you're a lot of desperate
hopeless
violent men with access to heavy-duty
weaponry
you know just recipe for problems you
know one one of the things that some
will assert is that to some degree given
the right
economic circumstances and political
circumstances
that anybody placed into the situation
you just described could end up as one
of these 21 year old hitmen
how do you react to such a claim i mean
could could it really be anybody
no i totally don't buy it i don't i
don't believe i don't believe that
you know if you look at that famous
study where people were supposedly
torturing with electroshocks and
that the study doesn't hold up that if
you look at that that didn't happen most
people refuse to
to torture you know lord of the flies is
fiction you know
so i definitely strongly disagree that
most of us have a potential hitman
inside us
what was the one i'm i'm speculating but
is there some risk to leaving that
lifestyle
in venezuela and the people were the
people that were at this camp were they
taking a risk by saying
i'm going to quit this yes and no they
were taking a risk but staying in as
hitman is even
more risky i mean you gotta you know
being a hitman is like
you know probably your your career is
like like it's like the nfl it's like
3.7 years and then it's over
and is part of that because there's a
risk of getting caught and prosecuted or
is most of the risk not from the legal
system
no these were a group of 30 men and and
they were down to like six of their six
of them were still alive
you know all almost all you know so
you know the average age of these guys
getting killed in uh combat
you know street urban combat was about
18 or 19. and they were all
most of them they were showing me their
bullet holes they all knew how to treat
bullet wounds which was pretty
remarkable you know
for 17 year olds to know how to treat
bullet wounds they used to piss on their
bullets before they go to combat because
they were sure
i don't think it's true but that that if
there was urine on the bullet that it
would cause a deeper infection on the
cops
wow these guys these guys were out there
um
and in fact a few days after my
interview the leader of the group was
caught by another group and uh
and chopped into pieces you know they
they more than murdered him so
this was a hyper violent crazy world and
i was trying to
just live with them and trying to get
them to go on camera and
tell me how i ended up this and there
are no easy answers you know i wish i
could say you know
keep your kids away from fortnite and
they won't be hit man but i don't think
it's that simple
no no it seems uh it seems not to be um
what are you what are you working on
right now
uh right now i'm doing a book on a true
story of a cruise ship
that gets hit by cobid it's a look at
how the passengers and the crew come
together this is kind of the last cruise
ship to go out before the world blocks
down
and uh the crew the you know the people
start to die they get sick and so it's a
story it's kind of a
it's a thriller but it's also a
beautiful story of how you know too
a community at sea 2000 people had to
find like a way to survive
because they were just they were adrift
for weeks no country would take them
how many people how many interviews do
you do for a book like that
150 180 wow wow and
is it even possible to keep the the sort
of
intertwined nature of the 150 stories
straight in your head or do you really
need to rely on on notes and
documentation
yeah no way i can do it my head no i got
set i got seven dollars most of my
brains otherwise occupied
hey i'm curious you know the the the
narrative fiction
uh a narrative nonfiction genre um
is is very interesting to me and i've
i've read you know
diverse uh narrative nonfiction
including your work and
i mentioned in my email to you ted
conover who i interviewed who's done
interesting work
john krakauer known for into thin air
and into the wild
what what are some of when you think of
the genre
what books and authors do you think of
i think a papillon you know the french
prisoner which may or may not be uh
narrative non-fiction because the
publisher on his deathbed admitted there
was a lot of uh
well went well beyond ben mendrich's
idea of creating dialogue that sounds
good
yeah so but but papillon fantastic
fantastic book there
into thin air still a classic um
you know perfect perfect storm the book
perfect storm is brilliant i mean
the movie the movie is well done but the
book is brilliant um
and um i guess those and i have to i
have to say what's interesting about the
one i did for
438 days is they did an audio version of
it
and i've never really paid much
attention to audiobooks but this one
has gone crazy and i think for any of
your listeners who
who like audio books or need an
inspiring story
it's about seven or eight hours but the
the the reader
george i don't know but he did a great
job we have a great you know really good
reader
and a thrilling tale so if people know
people who are depressed or
even suicidal or you know just going
stir crazy like most of us
uh the audio version of 438 days
half the time you can get it free on
amazon get it free if you can
but uh i think it's a it's a really it's
a
no because the book's a tool obviously i
make money on books but the whole point
of this book
uh was to hopefully stop people from you
know from suicide like
the goal of the book was if one person
reads this book and doesn't commit
suicide
you know that that was the goal the
fishermen and i set up from the
beginning because
the fishermen said look i've been
through mental stress physical stress
you know if i don't kill myself if i can
make it you can so i think there's a
really there's a really strong
um you know resilience and survival here
that goes
you know it touches a lot of people and
unfortunately a lot of people need that
message right now
well well well said uh we've been
speaking with jonathan franklin
investigative journalist writes for the
guardian author of 438 days
uh jonathan i so appreciate your time
today excellent well thank you very much
and i appreciate you know your questions
in a
beautiful interview well done